do you think you represent like the
typical modern woman walking out there
saying that they're not decent I
definitely don't represent that no then
we should really focus on what the
majority is because that's the majority
of girls walking around you're saying
but some people can say that you attract
what you are do you understand I believe
that social media and and the media
portrays a certain type I'm in a beauty
industry and I don't come across just
people in the social media that I see in
social media on a day-to-day basis that
isn't just what is out there I don't
agree there's no absolutes there's no
absolute you know what I mean there's no
absolutes no one said oh I don't think
all of most of the women I don't think
majority of the women are just how many
women have you dated
I don't date women exactly so you don't
really know what you're talking about
you know at the time it doesn't matter
what you say it doesn't matter because
you don't date them so you don't know
what you're talking about